>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> E.A. Aymar: Thank you so much
to everyone for coming out to Noir
at the National Book Festival
and thanks to the Library
of Congress for having us.
And we owe a special debt to
Colleen Slogan and Nicolas Brown
for arranging this event
and putting Noir at the Bar
in the national spotlight.
For those of you who've never
been to a Noir at the Bar,
it's an event that was
started about a decade ago
by the crime fiction book blogger
Pete Rozosky in Philadelphia.
Basically, a group of crime fiction
writers get together in a bar,
drink, and read short
stories or excerpts of novels.
Given the bar setting, the alcohol,
and the fact that crime fiction
writers tend to enjoy hanging
out in the outskirts of
respected literary society,
these readings are usually
raunchy and full of vulgarity,
but generally stayed true to
Noir or Neo-Noir tradition.
See, you learned something.
That's it, though.
That's all you'll learn tonight.
Given that this is a
family event and we'd
like to come back next year, we're
going to cut down on the raunch
and the swearing, but we'll still
have a fair amount of sketchiness
and shady characters,
which leads us right
to our first reader,
Louis Bayard [laughing].
There he is.
Louis eight novels include the Edgar
nominated, "The Pale Blue Eye,"
the New York Times notable,
"Mr. Timothy," and the recent
"Lucky Strikes" named one of the
best young adult titles of 2016.
His other novels include, "The
Black Tower," "The School of Night,"
and, "Roosevelt's Beast."
His essays and articles have
appeared in the Los Angeles
and New York Times, the Washington
Post, Salon, and book form.
He was also the author of
the Downton Abbey Recaps
for The New York Times, which
he embarrassingly called
"Downtown Abbey" well
into the second season.
Here's Louis.
[ Applause ]
>> Louis Bayard: I knew Ed
would spread lies about me.
I knew it.
It's just one of those things
that you knew was going to happen.
Well, welcome, everybody.
It's great to be here.
And thank you, Ed, for organizing us
all and getting us here [applause].
Yeah. I think it's hilarious we're
in the children's space right now
and I've been -- I'm already busily,
fiercely editing what
I have to read tonight.
Just a brief introduction.
A few years back, a
friend and I were leafing
through the DC Noir anthology
in would Jim Grady was
permanently featured.
I -- at least Jim Grady.
Maybe [inaudible].
And we realized suddenly that
there were no gay writers in it.
At least no writers that we'd
ever dated before between us.
And that led to this whole
conversation about Gay Noir
and whether such a
thing was even possible.
I, of course, contended that it was,
and to prove it, I wrote this story,
which was eventually published
in the City Paper's
annual fiction issue.
And, in fact, the story is
set in DC in the late '80s
and it's titled, "Chesapeake."
Not after the bay, I
should add, but the bar.
The Chesapeake house, which was
a really sleazy gay strip club
that used to draw a crowd
back in the day not very far
from here, in fact, very close by.
So this is how this story begins.
And this will be -- this will be PG.
A quarter century ago, or
maybe it was a million years,
I dated a full lipped, morally
unanchored charmer named Benjamin
who was in his third
year of Georgetown Law.
Better to say I tried to date him.
One night, because he
wouldn't cut me loose
and because I couldn't cut myself
loose, and because abjection came
as naturally to me then as
breathing, I followed him
without his knowledge from
Badlands down P Street.
He crossed DuPont Circle,
cut up New Hampshire, then,
a little shy of U Street
he paused in front
of a cinnamon brick
apartment building.
Like a mariner back
from the Spice Islands,
he gazed up at a second floor window
where a lamp was even now
extending a tongue of light.
He nodded to himself and then
made straight for the vestibule
where he waited for
the answering buzz.
In less than a minute his shadow,
unmistakable with his
lacrosse shoulders,
flickered across the
apartment's curtains.
This much I knew.
He would eat before
he did anything else.
Twenty minutes later an order
from Trio Pizza arrived.
I slipped in after the delivery guy,
followed him to the second floor,
watched a door spring open, saw
a pair of hands, not Benjamin's.
Apartment 203.
The blaze of revelation subsided as
I planted myself opposite the door.
If I were to have the confrontation
I wanted, needed, feared,
I'd have to sit there for
the rest of the evening,
my back against the wall.
Instead, I fell asleep and woke an
uncertain number of hours later.
A slender young man was standing in
the open doorway of apartment 203
in a pair of oversized sweatpants.
I lurched to my feet.
"Sorry, I'm Knox.
Like the fort.
Yeah." "Benjamin's gone, sweetie."
The voice was soft and low,
but with Carolina vowels.
"I doubt he even saw you there.
He was in a hurry to get to class."
Even in my sleep dazzled state
I could discern two things.
The young man was lying and this
lying was a form of charity.
"I'm Joey," he said.
"You should come in."
He made a pot of Irish breakfast
and poured it out in beer mugs.
He fed me Danish and Jiffy Pop.
He loaned me a comb.
The clock radio on his kitchen
counter had ticked just past 11AM
when he leaned across his
biscuit crate coffee table
and folded his soft, white fingers
around my long, thin, veined ones.
"You know, he's not
worth this," he said.
It occurred to me to deny it, but,
in the next breath, Joey said,
"I think I'm done with him too."
Decades later I'm still unpacking
the grace of that moment,
one man able, in just a
few words, to free two men,
to take them both out of the hunt.
"Do you have a place
to stay tonight?"
he asked. The answer was, "No."
I had just been evicted from
your apartment in Mount Pleasant.
My belongings were somewhere
in the attic over city lights
and I was waiting to hear
about a studio in Shaw.
I was 23. I'd come to
Washington not for a career,
but for a boy and I was dying.
But we all were.
"The couch pulls out," said Joey.
I lay on that couch
for about a week.
Joey cleaned around me.
He was a terror about dust.
And when he got tired of that, he
draped the Thursday classifieds
over me, "just in case," he said.
I wasn't very employable then.
Two years of a crunchy liberal arts
college in central Pennsylvania,
segments of office slavery,
a moderate acquaintanceship
with Word Star and MultiMate.
The old people here
will know those things.
But I beefed up my
resume as much as I dared
and flooded every office in town.
No one called back.
For cash I took gigs bussing
tables at the American Cafe,
answering phones at an
optometric association modeling
in the deep background
of a Sheraton print ad.
Sometimes, in a brief
flush of solvency,
I would offer to write
Joey a check for the rent,
but he waved his hand at me.
"When the ship comes in."
Never once did I see him write a
check of his own nor could I begin
to say whose name was on the lease
or who was paying for our groceries.
The bowls of citrus fruit on the
kitchen counter, the whole chickens
in the freezer, the packages
of Tuna Helper in the cupboard,
they were just there waiting.
Most days Joey slept until one or
two in the afternoon and it wasn't
until eight or nine in the
evening that he would put
on his denim shorts and his two polo
shirts and go off to see his friend.
Friend being, in this case, a
category rather than an individual.
The one job I knew him to
hold down was as a dancer
at the Chesapeake House
and only because he invited
on impulse to watch him perform.
Of the three guys dancing
on the runway that night,
he was the oldest, which
is to say he was 23,
but the most boyish in appearance.
He wore a jock strap, gray
athletic socks, and white Tretorns,
and he moved in a benign fog,
as though we were all
part of his dream.
I hustled him out of the place --
I hustled out of the
place before midnight.
Joey told me later I'd
missed the Scottish fantasia.
That's oblique enough.
Right? That's oblique enough.
[ Laughter ]
Our schedules were ideally matched.
If I wanted to bring
a trick home from --
[ Laughter ]
>> Keep going!
>> Louis Bayard: If I wanted
to bring a gentleman home
from Tracks [laughter] or the Frat
House, Joey would already be gone,
and by the time the gentleman
was living the next morning,
Joey was just coming back,
laden with rolls and oranges.
"Have a blessed day!"
he'd call out.
Our only moment of intersection
came late in the afternoon when,
like an old married couple, we would
sit on the chapped leather couch
and watch the squawk box.
Neither Joey nor I had any sure idea
of what was going on in the world,
but we both found the news
mysteriously restful, like listening
to traffic reports for
highways you would never travel.
So it was that, one afternoon
in June, our eyes came to rest
on a perfectly unremarkable
press conference,
three legislators before
a thicket of microphones.
The third man was halfway through
his remarks when Joey said, "Oh.
That's Earflaps."
Well, Earflaps, in addition to being
a Kansas republican is a sometime
patron of the Chesapeake House.
So, from here the tale
becomes increasingly twisted.
It includes blackmail, an unexpected
death, and rueful life lessons.
And you can Google the rest of it
on the internet at your leisure,
or maybe, cross your fingers,
look for it in the
next DC Noir anthology.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> E.A. Aymar: Do you have a
copy of your book [inaudible]?
>> Louis Bayard: Yes.
>> E.A. Aymar: OK [laughing].
Thanks, Louis, I guess [laughter].
Kathleen Barber's debut novel is
"Are You Sleeping" a suspense novel
out now from Simon and Schuster.
It's received praise
from Book Reporter,
Pop Sugar, and, yes, the Opera.com.
She attended the University
of Illinois
and Northwestern University School
of Law and now lives in Washington,
D.C. When she's not writing,
Kathleen enjoys traveling the world
with her husband and spending lots
and lots and lots and lots and lots
and lots and lots and lots
and lots of time on Twitter.
Here's Kathleen Barber.
[ Applause ]
>> Kathleen Barber: Thanks, Ed.
I do probably spend way too much
time on Twitter so if you're looking
for someone to follow, that's me.
Thanks so much for having me.
I've -- this is also a confusion --
I have never been to Noir at the Bar
so this is my first chance.
So if I do it wrong,
don't blame Ed, blame me.
OK. In retrospect, I should have
listened to our friends who scoffed
when we solicited recommendations
for a cat sitter.
"The cat will be fine," they said.
"You're going away for a
long weekend, not a month.
Just leave some food and water and
the cat will take care of himself."
But George Harrison, the cat,
not the Beatle, was our baby
and he had this bad habit of
wedging himself into spaces
from which he could not escape
like between the refrigerator
and the wall.
And I had horrible visions of him
slowly starving to death while James
and I drank wine with an ocean view.
So we found a cat sitter online.
Her name is Megan and she had
hair the color of cotton candy.
I didn't like the way
that she looked at James,
the way her mascaraed lashes drooped
and her teeth caught
her glossy lips,
but James said it was
all in my head.
Besides, George Harrison
seemed to like her curling
around her tattooed
ankles almost immediately
and that was all that mattered.
Our trip went a bit sideways
when someone stole my purse,
which had my driver's
license inside,
which meant I no longer had
the identification necessary
to board an airplane.
It could have been a complete
disaster, but Megan happily went
to our place, followed
our directions
to unlock a specific desk
drawer, and found my passport,
which she then overnighted
to the hotel.
So we gave her a bonus and
promised to recommend her to others
and then we forgot about her.
Months later, I came home and found
the cat's dishes in the middle
of the living room floor.
I looked to George
Harrison for explanation,
but he merely licked a paw
and stalked out of the room.
I shrugged and returned the dishes
to the kitchen where they belonged.
The next day I came home to
find the dishes moved again.
When I questioned James, he
looked at me like I was crazy.
"I haven't been doing that."
"Do we have a poltergeist?"
I wondered.
"Maybe you're just not
getting enough sleep, Hun."
I might have accepted
his explanation
if things hadn't started happening.
I found the silverware
piled on the table,
the books rearranged
spines facing in,
a wine glass we hadn't used
drying on a kitchen towel.
James accused me of doing
all this to screw with him
and I wondered if I was cracking up.
But then some money went missing.
Not much, but enough
that we noticed.
And I realized somebody
must be coming to the house.
But who? There are no
signs of a break-in
and James' mother was the
only one with a set of keys.
I doubted she was leaving her
retirement community to prank us.
And then we remembered Megan.
It was so obvious.
She must have made a
copy of our house keys.
"We know what you're
doing," James told her
over the phone, "and
you need to stop."
"I don't know what
you're talking about,"
she said coolly and hung up on us.
But the call put a stop to
things, or we thought it did.
One week later, James
called me into the study.
He gestured to an open desk
drawer and asked, his voice tight,
"Have you moved anything?"
I knew that drawer.
I knew what he was asking me.
That was the drawer where James
kept the pot he sold and I could see
from where I was standing
that it was strangely
empty except for a scale.
It wasn't like James was
some sort of drug dealer.
He was a hobbyist just procuring
some stuff from his younger cousin,
this skinny skateboard punk
who actually was a drug dealer,
and then, you know, distributing
it to some friends all
of whom were happy to reimburse
James for his cost and maybe also
to throw in a little extra
for his time and effort.
Hardly Walter White.
But still.
I kept my hands as far
away from that as possible
and I sure hadn't moved anything.
"Megan." I said.
"Who else could it have been?"
Because, of course, there
was no other answer.
We had told Megan where we
kept the keys to that desk,
had basically handed
her unfettered access
to our records and our secrets.
How had we have been so stupid
to think she would be put off
by one half-baked phone call?
"Do you think she's been taking
small amounts for weeks now?"
I asked, "Distracting us
from her theft with things
like moving the cat's dishes?
And do you think she took everything
in retribution for that call?"
"I don't know," James growled,
"but we have to get it back.
I'm going over there."
I ran to put on shoes
and met James by the car.
There was a cold, unfamiliar
look in his eyes,
something that made him look a bit
dangerous, which was ridiculous
because James couldn't
even hurt a spider.
He was always trapping
those things under glasses
and releasing them outside.
Still, I had a feeling
I needed to go with him
to make sure things
didn't get out of hand.
Megan seemed bewildered to find us
on her doorstep, which was ludicrous
because she had been breaking
into our home for weeks
and had just stolen
a bunch of drugs.
She held the door open less
than a foot and asked us
with faux concern whether
George Harrison was all right.
I snarled at her, "There's no
need to bring the cat into this."
James isn't a big man, but
he was bigger than Megan
and he pushed the door wide
open and barreled inside.
I followed him closing
the door behind us
as Megan's eyes got wide with worry.
I started to tell her that she
should stop looking so surprised.
She was the one who
had started all this,
when I noticed a paperweight
pinning down some mail by a table --
on a table by the front door.
And not just any paperweight.
It was our paperweight.
A glass globe that my late mother
had given us as a wedding gift.
We kept it in the study atop the
desk whose drawers Megan had raided.
I snatched it up and
waved it at her.
"You stole this too?"
She narrowed her eyes,
shook her head,
claimed she had no idea
what I was talking about.
"Just give us back our stuff."
James said reasonably.
She insisted she didn't
know what we meant,
that she didn't have
any of our stuff.
"Then what's this?"
I demanded waving the
paperweight at her.
She ignored me looking over my
shoulder with wide, frightened eyes,
her mouth dropped open slightly.
"That's not how she usually looks
at James," I thought absurdly.
I turned to follow her gaze and
saw James was holding a gun at her.
"Wow!" I said, "Where
did that come from?"
"That's it," Megan
said, all false bravado
as she pulled her phone
from her pocket.
"I'm calling the cops."
But I couldn't let her do
that, especially not now,
not with James waving
around some gun
that he got from who knows where.
I knew that, but I didn't
know what I could do about it.
I didn't know that I had
done anything about it
until I heard James'
shocked inhalation and looked
down to find Megan
crumpled on the carpet.
James looked at me horrified.
"What did you just do?"
I looked down at the
paperweight in my hand.
Blood dripped off the green
glass sphere staining the carpet.
I frowned.
I had always thought this
paperweight was blue.
But I couldn't worry
about shades of blue
and green while there was a
woman lying dead on the carpet.
We left her there.
We didn't know what else to do.
We thought back to every Law and
Order episode we had ever watched
and acted accordingly, wipe down
any surfaces we might have touched,
disposed of my shoes
in a random dumpster.
James wanted to throw away the
paperweight, but I couldn't bear
to part with it so I took it
home and washed it lovingly,
hid it underneath the bed.
And then we held our
collective breath.
When no one arrived to arrest us
the next day or the day after that
or the week after that, we
thought we were in the clear.
We thought we got away with murder.
And then I came home one afternoon
to find George Harrison's dishes
in the middle of the
living room floor.
I swallowed the panic that
was rising in my throat
and carried the dishes into the
kitchen where, on the kitchen table,
was a newspaper clipping held
down by two globe-shaped
paperweights,
one green and one blue.
Choking on terror I peered down
at the clipping, Megan's obituary.
And written across it in red marker
were the words, "Wrong answer.
Better luck next time."
So thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> E.A. Aymar: You guys
probably noticed I jumped
up here pretty nimbly the first two
readings, but I'm too 43-year-old
and too out of shape to keep doing
that so I'm doing the
stairs from now on.
Thank you, Kathleen!
We have Kathleen's book to
raffle off so check your tickets.
For ticket -- oh, no,
the number, 144301.
Really? Wow.
OK. Is it me?
144300.
I don't think we did these
raffle tickets right [laughing].
144308?
All right.
We'll do one more and
then we'll come back.
We'll figure out what
happened in the break.
144256.
>> Yay!
>> E.A. Aymar: Oh!
Oh, it worked.
OK. Good. All right.
We're on base.
[ Applause ]
I'd encourage you not to
applaud after the raffle tickets.
The winner did nothing.
Literally nothing to win.
Our next reader is some shmuck.
Oh, it's me.
My most recent novel is tearfully
titled, "You're As Good As Dead."
I also write a monthly column for
the Washington Independent Review
of Books and I'm the Managing Editor
of The Thrill Begins on behalf
of the International
Thriller Writers.
For this reading, I'll be joined
by jazz singer Sara Jones.
Sara won the Billie Holiday Vocal
Competition and sang for years
with the US Army Field
Band Soldier's Chorus.
She performs at venues
throughout the region
and teaches at Towson University.
This story is called, "I
Love You, But I Don't."
Jake hurried through the
crowd on Main Street.
He loosely held a metal
chain in a sweaty right hand.
Meredith tugged his left.
"Come with me!"
she urged him.
Buildings burned on
either side of them.
The riots had started a half
hour earlier and this section
of the city had been
abandoned by authority.
"How much money is
going to be there?"
Jake asked.
"Lots." Meredith stopped
walking, looked sideways at him
as looters rushed past,
"You getting nervous?"
He stopped with her and shrugged
trying to come off as nonchalant.
"I'm good."
Meredith kept staring.
"No. I am.
It's just I should
have brought a shotgun
or something instead of this chain.
I'm not really a chain guy."
"But you're a shotgun guy?"
"You're saying that like you
don't think I am [laughing]."
"I don't. I love you, but I don't."
Meredith started walking again.
Jake followed her.
They'd been watching TV in his
tiny apartment when the results
of the court case had
been announced.
A white cop who had shot two
black children had been acquitted.
The shooting had been videotaped
and the cop had shouted
racial epithets as he fired.
And right before the trial he'd
had, "I shoot black people,"
tattooed on his forehead, and,
"I'm definitely guilty,"
tattooed on his neck.
But a Grand Jury still
acquitted him.
The city had already been close to
collapse and that pushed it too far,
broke something inside of
everyone no matter their race.
The crowd thinned as looters headed
to the rich stores
where the cops waited.
Jake followed Meredith
in a different direction
through side streets until they
reached a small, secluded shop.
"M&W Musical Instruments?"
Meredith nodded.
"This store is loaded.
Trust me."
Jake tried the door,
"And it's locked."
Meredith looked at the long
window facing the street then
down to his chain.
"Well, it looks like you
got a key," she smiled.
And that little smile
sparked something
in Jake the way it always did.
It took one swing for
the entire window
to shatter sprinkle
the ground with glass.
He hefted the chain in
his hand feeling proud,
glanced over at Meredith to
see if she was impressed,
but she was already walking
between rows of instruments.
"So, where's the safe?"
"It's in the office."
Meredith walked slowly like
she was wading through water,
her fingers traced the
curved wood of a harp.
"The owner keeps important
stuff out of sight."
Jake nodded.
And how do you know him?
"He's my husband."
Everything stopped.
"You're married?"
"Just a little bit."
"A little bit?"
"Jake, it's OK.
We're going to separate.
He's not very nice to me."
"I can't believe this."
"This store means everything
to him," Meredith said.
"Let's burn it down."
"What? Burn it down?"
"That store across
the street's on fire.
We can spread it over here."
"What if someone sees us?"
Meredith reached into her pocket,
pulled out a small,
silver hand gun."
Jake pointed, "That's a gun!
I didn't know you had a gun!"
"You seem more upset about
the gun than I'm married."
"Oh, I'm a democrat."
Jake rubbed his forehead.
"Why do you lie to me?"
Meredith ignored him, walked
deeper into the store.
"I didn't think we'd be
together forever," Jake lied
as he followed her, "but
it's been a couple of months.
How could you not tell
me you're married?"
Meredith wasn't listening.
She was staring at
something Jake couldn't see.
When she spoke again, her voice
was soft and dreamy and distant.
"He taught me to sing."
"Who?" Meredith ignored his
question, but it didn't matter.
Jake knew who.
"We'd sit in that small room
in the back facing each other
so close our knees touched.
When he shut the door,
it was so quiet,
I felt like we were
buried underground.
That was before he changed,
before the hitting."
"Why didn't you tell
me any of this?"
But her mind was somewhere else.
Her body in two words, a foot
in each she started to sing.
>> Sara Jones: You
don't know what love is
until you've learned the
meaning of the blues,
until you've loved the
love you've had to lose.
You don't know what love is.
You don't know how the lips
hurt until you've kissed and had
to pay the cost, until
you've flipped your heart
and you have lost.
You don't know what
love is [singing].
>> E.A. Aymar: Jake walked out.
He stopped and looked back
at Meredith one last time,
stared at her tall
silhouette in the middle
of that dark store,
and then he left.
He walked nearly a mile
dragging his chain behind him
like a disappointed snake.
Meredith had always
seemed unattainable to him,
but there is something about
that distance that drew him.
No. Not the distance.
The moments it was absent.
The surprising moments when she
turned toward Jake completely his,
carefree and excited.
Walking away from her was unreal.
It made his insides feel like
a box of loose puzzle pieces.
And then he heard her singing.
>> Sara Jones: You don't know
how hearts burn for a love
that cannot live yet never dies,
until you've faced its
dawn with sleepless eyes.
You don't know what love is.
>> E.A. Aymar: It was impossible.
He was a mile away and
the night wasn't quiet.
There were shouts from Main Street,
sirens, the low roar of fire.
Jake turned and followed the sound
all the way back to the shop.
He stood in the shadows and stared
inside, stared at Meredith's body
on the ground and a man
kneeling next to her.
Jake recognized him from a
photo he'd seen on her phone.
"Who's that?"
he'd asked.
"Oh." Meredith had replied, "No one.
Some guy named Will."
Now will rose to his feet
and Jake stepped back deeper
into the shadows.
The nearby fire warmed him,
cast enough light for him
to see Will walk over to a wall
and rest his head against it,
and to see the gun Will held.
Jake hadn't realized
he was inside the store
until the glass cracked underfoot.
He knelt next to Meredith,
turned her over,
saw the hole where
her face used to be.
"She was trying to
burn my store down."
Will pointed to a burning
two by four in the corner.
"I saw her carrying that.
She was trying to burn
my store down."
Jake wasn't aware that he was
wrapping the chain around his fist.
He barley understood he was standing
or that he'd thrown a punch,
not until an ache from
the chain reverberated
up his arm and Will fell back.
Will looked for the gun, but
it had flown out of his hand.
Jake punched him again
this time across the jaw.
Will hit the floor hard,
uncontrolled, unconscious.
Jake enrolled the chain from
his fist and picked up the gun.
He perched his foot on
the other man's chest,
aimed the gun at his head, "this is
for Meredith," he said, and fired.
The bullet exploded
into his own foot.
Jake cried out and fell
down grabbing his ankle,
the pain making him see white.
Meanwhile, the fire had
spread to the walls.
The front of the store collapsed.
Smoke whirled toward
Jake like a sheet.
He dragged himself away from it.
"The entrance should be
this way, shouldn't it?"
Jake wasn't sure anymore.
He was blind in the dark,
coughing, his foot bursting in pain.
Smoke filled his mouth until
it felt like something solid
and lodged in his throat.
Jake tried another
direction still blind.
His arms gave out as
the smoke thickened.
Everything around him burned.
The end.
[ Applause ]
Thanks. And thanks to Sara.
Isn't she really good?
Isn't she great?
[ Applause ]
So I got a copy of my latest book to
raffle off and Sara has two copies
of her CD, Daydream a Little.
So if this works right, 144292.
144292. Oh!
Molly! You -- you can get Sara's CD.
That's a good one.
Yeah. She has my book.
144298. Oh!
And the other copy of Sara's CD.
And 144306.
144306.
All right.
144305.
Really? OK.
We'll do one more.
144297.
No one? Really?
All right.
OK. All right.
I don't know.
I'm not good at raffling [laughing].
Colleen Shogan is the author
of the Washington Whodunit mystery
series featuring Capitol Hill
Detective Kit Marshall, "Calamity
at the Continental Club," third book
of the series came out
in July of this year.
She won't a Next Generation Indie
Award for best mystery in 2016
and was RONE finalist
for mystery in 2017.
She works at the Library of Congress
and helps lead the
division responsible
for the National Book Festival.
So everyone here has to
be really nice to her
if you want to come back next year.
An inexplicably proud Pittsburgh
native, Colleen now lives
in Arlington, Virginia
with her husband, Rob,
and her beagle mutt, Conan.
Here's Colleen Shogan.
[ Applause ]
>> Colleen Shogan: Thanks, Ed.
It's been a long day, but I'm
happy to be here tonight and I hope
in future years for the
book festival we're able
to do even more evening programming
featuring local writers and authors.
That's sort of our goal and
we hope to build that out
in future years for
the book festival.
So stay tuned and keep coming
to see us year after year.
I'm going to read a
chapter from my latest book,
"Calamity at the Continental
Club," and, as Ed said,
I'll give you a little
bit of a setup.
Kit Marshall is a Capitol
Hill Washington, D.C. sleuth
and in this installment
of the series she's attending
a historical society reception
and weekend at a very
fancy Washington,
D.C. member's only club
called the Continental Club.
And, as usually what happens to Kit,
she happens to find a dead body.
So this is the point in the
story in which, you know,
the mystery really gets started.
Without a moment's hesitation,
I sprung to the man's side.
The face was contorted,
but I still recognized him.
It was Grayson Bancroft dressed in
the same suit he'd worn to dinner.
Obviously, Grayson never
made it to bed last night.
His skin was extremely
pale, not a good sign.
Tentatively, I reached
to feel for a pulse.
After grasping his stone cold
hand for only a second I recoiled.
The president of the
Mayflower Society was dead.
Now, it was time to panic.
The eerie silence consuming the
entire building prevented me
of lending out a scream.
Instead, I scrambled around the
corner and flew down the last flight
of stairs to reach
the main entrance.
The concierge desk sat empty.
Didn't anyone start the day early
in Washington even at
the Continental Club?
The delicious aroma of freshly
baked rolls wafted in my direction.
Of course the Continental
Club was a prime location
for a beltway power breakfast.
I followed my nose, which
led me to the entrance
of the garden dining room.
Two well-dressed businessmen
were waiting to be seated.
"Could someone help me?"
I asked. My black capris
running pants, a hoodie,
and yellow tennis shoes
didn't inspire confidence.
The club's host took one look
at me and wrinkled his nose.
"I'll be with you in
a moment, ma'am.
As soon as seat these
two gentlemen."
Given the circumstances,
waiting was out of the question.
"Sir, I'm sorry.
But I need your assistance now!"
My voice was only a
decibels shy of a scream.
I'd gotten his attention.
"Please. I have to ask
you to wait your turn."
The two men in suits shook
their heads in disgust.
He left me no choice.
I hadn't wanted to spoil
breakfast for the eager diners.
"There's a dead man upstairs.
He's inside the library."
That did it.
All three men stared
at me mouths agape.
Given their reactions, I might as
well have announced the arrival
of Queen Elizabeth's corpse.
The host stammered,
"What did you say?"
I cleared my throat and spoke in my
clearest, most sophisticated voice,
"His name is Grayson Bancroft.
I don't know what happened to
him, but someone might want
to attend to the matter."
I turned on my heels and retreated.
The club staffer followed
behind apparently deciding
that the two guests were
no longer a priority.
When he caught up with me, he
put his hand on my shoulder.
"Can you show me..."
and his voice trailed off.
I turned to face him.
"The body?"
He gulped.
"Yes." "Follow me."
I motioned toward the stairs.
Once we reached the first floor
landing we continued past the
portrait and reached
Franklin's statue.
I pointed in the direction
of the library entrance.
Fortunately, although not for
Grayson, the body remained
in exactly the same spot.
"He's the leader of the Historical
Society group we're hosting
for the next three
days," the host said.
Despite my best efforts, I
couldn't hide my exasperation.
"That's what I was
trying to tell you."
He knelt down besides Bancroft.
"Are you sure he's dead?"
"I'm no medical examiner,
but his hand is cold
and I can't detect a pulse.
And he's not breathing.
If you could stay here, I'm going to
call an ambulance and the police."
I nodded. If I'd had my phone
I could have texted Doug
until the alerts on
his device woke him.
My best laid plans for a jog
this morning had gone awry.
I squatted next to the
body for a closer look.
The twisted features
definitely belonged
to the man I met the night before,
enough to make a positive
identification.
Unfortunately, Bancroft
didn't seem to be at peace.
Grayson had been in
relatively good shape.
His weight appeared average
and he was likely a few years
shy of Medicare eligibility.
If he suffered from an
illness like cancer,
the effects of such a serious
disease certainly weren't apparent.
Was it a heart attack?
Perhaps he smoked.
I got closer to his
face and sniffed.
I was particularly sensitive
to the smell of cigarettes.
Although I detected the lingering
fragrance of a men's cologne,
there was no hint of tobacco.
Something seemed odd about
the placement of the body.
If he'd been a victim of cardiac
arrest, wouldn't he have fallen
to the ground in a crumpled heap?
Instead, Bancroft was lying
perfectly flat on his back,
arms and legs spread wide.
It was as though he'd
been in the middle
of making a snow angel
when he'd died.
I returned to the library
and bent down again.
The expression on his face
seemed frozen like something
out of the ordinary had happened to
him and he'd been unable to react.
There was no other
way to describe it.
Grayson Bancroft had
been surprised to die.
When staring at the
expression of shock
on Bancroft's face
I noted the small,
red mark on the dead man's neck.
It was on the left side
inches above the fitted collar
of his buttoned down dress shirt.
It was quite noticeable and I was
almost certain it hadn't been there
the night before.
Leaning over the body, I moved
closer for a better look.
It wasn't a birth mark
or a mosquito bite.
To my untrained eye, it
appeared to be a puncture wound.
"Who are you and what
are you doing?"
I drew back immediately at the sound
of an authoritative female voice.
A petite woman whipped
out a badge and flashed.
"Detective Maggie Glass,
DC Metro Police."
I stood up and offered her
my hand, "Kit Marshall.
I discovered the body."
The detective was joined
by several EMTs.
Their visit would be brief
because I was certain
that Grayson Bancroft was deceased.
I moved away while the emergency
medical personnel surrounded the
body and confirmed the death.
Glass motioned for me
to exit the library.
The middle-aged detective
was short in stature,
but I could tell she meant business.
Her brown hair was
pulled back in a ponytail
and she wore a fitted black
suit that was professional,
yet also sporty in case a
hot pursuit was called for.
Silver button earrings
provided a feminine touch.
She pulled out a notebook
and grabbed a pen from
her jacket pocket.
"Miss Marshall, you're a guest
here at the Continental Club?"
I briefly described the reason for
our visit and explained I lived
in Washington, D.C.
metropolitan area.
"Where do you work?"
Apparently the district police
ask this question as an opener.
Maybe they also attended too
many K Street cocktail parties.
"Capitol Hill.
I work for a chief
of staff for a member
of the House of Representatives."
"A political type I see.
No surprises there.
How did you come to
discover the deceased?"
MY workout attire corroborated
my story
and Glass didn't question why
I stumbled across Grayson.
She continued to write
furiously in her notebook.
Without looking up,
she kept talking.
"Only a few more questions,
Miss Marshall.
This seems open and shut.
The coroner will take it from here.
It was most likely a heart
attack or an aneurysm.
We see these all the time and
men of the deceased's age group."
I cleared my throat.
That got Glass's attention.
She glanced up from scribbling
furiously in her notepad and asked,
"Do you have something to add?"
"Detective, I'm sure you
noticed the odd position
of the body on the floor."
"Not really.
I wanted to let our medical
experts confirm the death.
Let's take another look."
She motioned with the pen
that I should follow
her inside the library.
Glass circled the body several times
and paused to write in her notebook.
She indicated the medics
should join us.
"Fellas, does this look
like a heart attack
or an otherwise natural
death to you?"
The younger guy shook
his head, "Seems weird.
Like he hit the ground
and just froze."
The other EMT rubbed his chin,
"Can't see I've seen anything
like this in real life.
It reminds me of something
I saw on cable TV."
"What do you mean?"
I asked. "You know.
One of those channels with
the historical documentaries.
It's like that town in Italy
where the volcano erupted
thousands of years ago."
"Pompeii?"
I offered.
He raised a triumphant
finger, "You've got it!
Everyone was killed and then
preserved instantly by ash.
This guy looks like one of those
unlucky people stopped dead
in his tracks."
Glass stared at the paramedic for
a long moment before speaking.
"Well, one thing's for certain.
There was no volcano in the
middle of the Continental Club.
So what killed him?"
The detective bent down
to take a closer look.
She immediately noticed the red mark
on the dead man's neck and motioned
for the History Channel
watching medic to join her.
"What do you see here?
Is it a wound?
A bug bite?"
The paramedic hesitated
almost as if to say
that answering her question exceeded
his pay grade, but he complied
without protest even
whipping out a small pen light
to shine on Bancroft's neck.
"I'm not a medical examiner,
ma'am, but that's not
from a mosquito," he concluded.
Glass grabbed the pen light
and peered at the small blotch.
"That's helpful, but what is it?"
"Maybe an injection site.
You can see the dot in the center.
There's a bit of blood around it."
Detective glass must have agreed
with the medic's conclusion.
After examining Grayson's neck
again she leaned back and said,
"Thank you for your help.
Everything had happened so fast
I hadn't had much time to think
about the consequences of
finding the mysterious mark
on Bancroft's body, an
odd and inauspicious start
to my morning had suddenly turned
into something more sinister.
Detective Glass jotted
down more notes
and tapped her pen to her forehead.
To no one in particular
she stated the obvious,
"I don't like how this
is shaping up."
I drew nearer.
"Detective, I'm clearly not
going for a run this morning.
Do you mind if I return to my
room so I can speak with my fiance
and put on more appropriate
clothes?"
With an absentminded sideways
glance, Glass answered, "Of course."
Then, she quickly added, "Don't
go anywhere else, Miss Marshall.
You may have just become a
key witness to a murder."
I was no stranger to
those fateful words.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> E.A. Aymar: Thank you, Colleen.
Oh. We can do the raffle.
Do you have a book to give away?
She does.
All right.
Calling number 144255.
>> Right here.
>> E.A. Aymar: Oh!
Someone -- OK.
It worked kind of.
Con Lehane's newest book, "Murder
at the 42nd Street Library,"
came out earlier this
year from Minotaur.
It's the first in a new series
featuring Raymond Ambler,
Curator at the 42nd Street Library's
fictional crime fiction collection.
He's also been published in Alfred
Hitchcock's Mystery Magazine
and has a different mysteries series
featuring a New York City bartender
named Brian McNulty.
Over the years Con has been a
college professor, union organizer,
labor journalist, disciple,
and has tended bar at two dozen
or so drinking establishments.
He teaches fiction
writing and mystery writing
at the Writer's Center in Bethesda
and is the only person I know
who still uses a fax machine.
Here's Con Lehane.
[ Applause ]
>> Con Lehane: I'm really surprised
about that fax machine thing.
Is that a -- I didn't know
they had been replaced.
I also think this is the first time
in the history of Noirs at the Bar
that we've had a signing
interpreters so thank you.
It's a great --
[ Applause ]
So Ed said who the series is.
So that pretty much covers it.
This is the second
book in the series.
It's called "Murder in
the Manuscript Room"
and it's coming out in November.
Maybe -- all right.
So I'm going to read
a short section.
Now, you should be able to follow.
Ambler is the Raymond Ambler,
the Curator of the
Crime Fiction Collection
at the New York Public Library,
the 42nd Street Library.
What struck Ambler
was a coincidence.
A week before he'd gotten a
call from an upstate prison --
actually the call was from
his son who is in prison.
You have to read the first book
to understand why he was there.
But a lifer there told his son
he was a friend of his father
and wanted to talk to him.
The prisoner, Devon Thomas, in
fact had been Ambler's friend,
a very good friend from 6th
grade until Devon dropped
out of high school at 16 to run
with the Black Peoples' Party the
last time Ambler had seen him except
in a Daily News photo
wearing handcuffs.
On his monthly visit to his
son the previous Saturday,
Ambler looked up his friend.
Devon told him he was in prison
for a murder he didn't commit.
"My kid brother did the murder."
Devon told him.
His hard stare faltered.
"Trey was a snitch.
I took the rap because I knew
someone would kill him in here."
"And now?"
Ambler asked?
"He died a couple of weeks ago."
A skeptical person might
doubt Devon's story
that he'd spent his adult life in
prison for a crime he didn't commit
out of loyalty to his brother.
Ambler believed him.
He'd met Devon in 6th grade
at a new school for Ambler.
The first day he was
surrounded in the hallway
by a half dozen would-be -- he
was surrounded in the hallway
by a half dozen would-be hoodlums
taunting him for some imagined
or fabricated slight when he
felt an arm around his shoulder.
It was Devon, who amiably
brushed aside the thugs
and walked him into the classroom.
Ambler knew some of the history
behind Devon's arrest and conviction
because it was major news
in the tabloids at the time.
In the early '80s, a group of truck
drivers took on a corrupt union
in the garment trucking industry.
One of the leaders of the
insurgence, Richard Wright,
was murdered shortly after he was
elected president of the local
in a government monitored election.
"Devon Thomas killed
him," the newspapers said,
"in a feud between rival
gangs over drug territory."
"No way I killed him," Devon said.
"I loved him like a father.
Trey was a rat.
A snitch. I didn't know.
Never thought it.
Never suspected until he
got scared and told me.
Told me his handler
told him to off Richard.
When he told me, I wanted
to kill Trey myself.
You become a snitch because
you're paid or you do it
to keep yourself out of prison.
His handler from the NYPD
told Trey he'd get off.
Then, something went wrong and
the handler told Trey he'd have
to plead to manslaughter.
They'd get him out in three years.
Trey told me he wacked Richard
and was going up for it.
I couldn't let him do it.
I took the rap.
I thought I'd get the same deal.
They told Trey manslaughter,
a three year bid.
Ha! I got life."
Devon's hair, still
kinky, had turned gray.
Tight curls now where years
ago it was a giant afro.
His eyes were clear, still
hard, still something friendly
in them too, a flash of
kindness behind the hard.
His skin darker than
Ambler remembered,
his features as much European as
African, a slender nose, thin lips.
He'd developed the prison
body, muscular, athletic.
As he talked he'd reach out
now and again putting his hand
on Ambler's forearm to make
sure he had his attention,
to reinforce the connection.
He did this now.
"Trey got the AIDS.
I got compassion leave the
visit him in the hospice.
He was out of his head a lot.
Right before he died he told
me he didn't kill Richard.
They killed him."
"Who's 'They?'" Ambler asked?
Devon shook his head.
"I don't know.
I got some ideas.
I've been going back over
what happened back then.
I'm using the prison
library, but it's slow.
I thought you might see what you
can find in that library of yours
about what happened back then.
I read about you.
That's what you do, right?
You find out what really
happened when someone was killed?"
"Not exactly," Ambler said.
"You can tell the truth now, right?
Your brother's dead.
You didn't commit the murder."
Devon's eyes locked on Ambler's.
"Who'd believe me?"
Ambler nodded.
"I know you, Ray.
We were bros."
Devon laughed.
It began as a kind of giggle
catching on like an uncertain motor
until it became a chuckle
and then a full out laugh.
The sound of it rolled back the
years to the endless summers he
and Devon, baseball gloves
and bats over their shoulders,
rambled through Flatbush
seeking out pick-up games
in schoolyards and vacant lots.
The nights they played stick
ball under the street lights
between the parked cars on E and
19th Street off Beverley Road.
OK. That's it.
Thank you.
I have a book to raffle off if
you think you can handle it.
Eh [laughing]?
>> E.A. Aymar: Thank you, con.
Please leave the stage.
[ Laughter ]
Con has a book to raffle off
and the lucky winner is
-- you applaud for raffle?
>> Oh, no.
I [inaudible].
>> Oh, OK.
Sorry. Sorry.
I was very confused.
144296. Oh!
Hey! The lovely lady in the back.
[ Applause ]
That's my mom [laughing].
Shawn Reilly Simmons is the author
of "The Red Carpet Catering
Mysteries" featuring Penelope
Sutherland, an onset movie caterer,
and of several short stories
appearing in various anthologies.
She serves on the Board of Malice
Domestic, is a member of the Dames
of Detection, and an
editor at Level Best Books,
which has published many
award winning anthologies
that writers are often
desperate to appear in
and will do anything
to curry her favor.
On an unrelated note,
Shawn, you're very pretty.
Here she is.
[ Applause ]
>> Shawn Reilly Simmons: Thanks, Ed.
You're very pretty too.
I'm going to read a story called
"Humble Pie" and it appears
in this anthology Noir at the Salad
Bar, Culinary Tales with a Bite.
Sort of the anti-cozy
culinary anthology.
Humble Pie.
Ivy always gave me that look.
Her tight, prissy little lip twist.
The laugh I could see
right behind her eyes.
I smiled back like I always do.
I stepped up to her judging
table to set down my pie.
"Same kind as last year," Ivy said
with a small shake of her head.
"I love mincemeat pie,
especially near to the holidays."
I smiled again.
"Well, good luck to you then, Sissy.
This might finally be your year."
Sissy. She was always calling me
that even though she knew
damn well I was married now
and should be called Mrs. Cecilia
Burns if she wanted to be proper.
Ivy's eyes opened wide and
she fussed at her orange,
polka dotted scarf when
she saw Jean Brodie walking
up with a lattice topped
deep dish apple.
She just about toppled her chair
over backwards jerking up like
that from her seat reaching
across the table to take the pie
from Jean acting all
friendly and whatnot.
I heard Ivy call Jean a
dirty bitch -- b-word --
once in the bathroom
back in school just
because her daddy owned the
junk yard and repair shop.
Ivy didn't know I heard her.
I had my feet propped up on
the toilet like I used to do
so I could hear what
those girls were saying
when they thought no one was around.
I guess Ivy thinks Jean's all right
now since she's rick on account
of her husband owning the one
and only car dealership in town.
Owned. It's Jean's now.
Her husband fell over one day on the
lot a year or so back right in front
of a couple he'd just
taken for a test drive
in a brand new Buick Riviera.
I heard he clutched his chest
and called out for Jean.
He was romantic like that.
"Jean, you just have to come
up to our next fundraiser,"
Ivy said through her smile,
still tugging at her scarf
in that anxious way of hers.
"We're raising money to buy a new
nativity scene for the square."
"So I've heard," said Jean.
She folded her hands in front
of her showing off her
expensive leather gloves.
"I like your scarf," I interrupted.
Jean and Ivy both looked at me.
Ivy smirked and tilted her
head, then turned back to Jean.
Jean squinted at me like I had
a toe growing between my eyes.
"Like I was saying.
The little Christ baby from our old
nativity, the paint's all worn away.
It's not right having him sit out
there all chip-faced and decrepit.
It goes against God."
"How are you doing, Cecilia?"
Jean Brodie asked me a question.
"Fine, thanks.
And you?" "I'm all right.
And how is Mr. Burns?"
I beamed and reached up a
hand to straighten my hat.
"We're both just fine.
Thanks for asking."
"Glad to hear it," Jean said.
"I do see your husband from
time to time always out
and about in his tow truck.
Sometimes he pulls old trade-ins
to the lot that don't run anymore."
"Oh, he's on the road all the time,"
I said tripping over my words.
"We'd have two or three
babies by now
if he could just be
home more often."
"Yes. I'm sure that's
true," Jean said wistfully.
"Just remember, life's little
blessings come along right
when they're supposed to."
I nodded and smiled
like I always do.
The children at the next
table rubbed sticky paint
onto maple leaves and pressed
them onto construction paper.
"I just remembered," Jean said
acting all surprised, "Ivy,
weren't you and Marvin
king and queen
of the Fall Fest back in the day?"
"Oh, yes, we were," Ivy said acting
like she couldn't quite remember.
"But that was so long ago."
"Yes, I suppose we've
all gotten a lot older.
Well, you ladies enjoy the seasons,"
Jean said in her grand way.
She waved to someone in
the crowd and drifted off.
I turned back to Ivy.
Her eyes burned into the
back of Jean's cashmere coat.
She had that same look on her
face that she did back in school,
but this time she was too afraid
to call Jean a b-word out loud
in public not that
we were all grownups.
A surprise bubble of laughter
rolled up my chest and I coughed
into my fist to keep it down.
I sat on a cold, metal folding
chair and watched the rest
of the fall fest pies come in.
I knew mine was different.
It would be the one they'd
all be talking about after.
When it came time for judging,
Ivy and her friends hovered
over the gingham tablecloth
all official
and whatnot in their frilly aprons.
They tasted little bits of pie
from their plastic forks acting
out for all of us like they didn't
ever take big bites of anything.
Then, they joked about getting
fat and watching their waistlines
like judging a pie contest was the
last thing they wanted to be doing.
I watched especially close
when Ivy tasted mine.
I pressed my own hand
to my narrow side.
It was almost done hurting
from that last time.
Marvin was good about leaving the
marks under my clothes so when I was
out and about in town no one
could see my black and blues.
I could keep my head up and look
at everyone in the eye that way.
I slipped my hand into my pocket
and felt the folded piece of paper,
smoothed edges from all those times
I had folded it and refolded it ever
since I found it last
week on laundry day.
"We have a winner!"
Ivy shouted.
She stuck the big blue ribbon on the
table in front of Jean's apple pie.
Some people tried to clap
through their gloves while balancing
flimsy cups of cider in their hands.
They sounded like that hurt
bird I found in the yard
that time flapping its
wings for no reason just
because it thought it should.
I knew that bird would
never fly again.
Jean made her way to the table
and took a flowery bow thanking
all the judges one by one.
She took an extra-long time
thanking Ivy holding both her hands
with her own and pumping
them up and down.
They looked like a couple
of overdressed milk maids
churning a pot of butter.
Then, Jean turned and smiled right
at me before she wandered off
in the crowd ribbon in hand.
I heard a few sirens that night,
but they were too far off for me
to place what part of town.
I was in my usual chair
at the kitchen table,
the radio playing John
Coltrane low from the counter.
Marvin didn't have a taste for music
that he said white
people had nothing to do
with so I always kept an
eye out for the headlights
so I can turn it off quick just to
keep him from shouting about it.
I ate my pie slowly, one bite of
minced meat and a bite of apple,
taking sips of black
coffee in between.
The letter I found written
in that prissy tight
handwriting lay open on the table.
I read it maybe 100 times.
Ivy still made those little
curlicue shapes on her y's
like she hadn't grown up at all.
I bid on both pies after the
contest, had to pay a lot more
for Jean's than mine, of course.
The headlights skidded across
the windows and I looked up,
my heart beat slowing to a thud.
I folded Ivy's note and
put it in my apron pocket.
My legs tingled when I stood up
and went to shut off the radio.
The clock told me I'd been
sitting there for over an hour.
I'd eaten almost half of both pies.
The kitchen door rattled open.
"They're gone," Jean
said, her cheeks flushed.
She pulled her hat off and let her
hair spill down over her shoulders.
"Gone?" I asked.
"They're dead," Jean said.
"Break failure out on
the new two-lane highway.
Headlong collision
with a big wheeler.
Marvin's tow truck was parked at
the edge of the Fall Fest lot.
Just took one snip."
"What about the truck driver?
Is he all right?"
I asked. Jean broke out a laugh
and pulled off her gloves,
her fingers black with grease.
"He'll live.
It's all perfect."
Jean put her hands on my
cheeks and pulled me close.
She kissed me that way that I like,
gentle at first, then more grown up,
her tongue sliding up against mine.
I kissed her back like I always do.
"I got you something," she
said when we came up for air.
"What?" She pulled Ivy's
orange polka dotted scarf
from her coat pocket
and handed it to me.
"How did you get this?"
"Ivy gave it to me when I promised
to come to the next fundraiser."
Jean laughed so hard
she lost her breath.
I smiled and kissed her
again like I always do.
[ Applause ]
>> E.A. Aymar: Thank you, Shawn.
Shawn is raffling off a copy of
the anthology her book appeared in.
And the lucky number is 144310.
Oh! OK. I'll bring it to you.
Yeah. OK. James Grady's first novel
became Robert Redford's Three Days
at the Condor.
Aren't you fancy, James?
And is under development for a TV
series scheduled for next year.
Since Condor, Grady has
published more than a dozen novels
and three times as many short
stories across genres working
at Hollywood as a screenwriter for
HBO and CBS and as a staff writer
for the late TV empire
creator Steven Curnow.
He spent four years as an
investigative reporter here in DC
and has won literary awards
from Japan, Italy, and France.
Montana born and raised,
Grady now lives just
up the Red Line in Silverspring.
As an FYI, I asked and, no, he will
not introduce you to Robert Redford.
But here's James Grady.
[ Applause ]
>> James Grady: I thought Robert
Redford was coming to hear Con read
so I've been looking
around hoping to spot him,
but I must have been misinformed.
This is such a gas to be here
at the National Book Festival
and it's a double gas because
the book I'm reading from,
"Montana Noir," comes out Tuesday.
The Montana Noir anthology
of short fiction is part
of an astonishing legacy that now
encompasses 80 books published in,
I think, 19 countries.
There have been two
DC noir collections.
I hope there will be a third.
My short story takes
place eventually
in my home town of Shelby.
The story's called,
"The Road You Take."
A big blue sky arched over
that prairie highway driven
by a low, white minivan.
Roxy road behind Desiree
who'd called shotgun
when they left last night's
motel in a pine trees
and good money town
across the mountains.
Shotgun meant riding next
to Bear, 300 plus pounds
of watch-out crammed
behind the steering wheel.
He stank of weed he wouldn't
share, cigarettes, and whiskey,
plus you might catch a paw
if he thought you'd sassed
or he simply got the
itch to pop somebody.
But Desiree packed 60 extra
pounds of flesh on her 5'8"
in stiletto heels frame and the
big girl knew how to take a hit.
Cherry road on Roxy's left
past the cooler behind Bear,
her golden blonde dye
job had more class
than Desiree's motel sink peroxide.
Cherry craned to see
where they were going
as if there were some
destination besides the next gig.
She was a few high school years
ahead of Roxy who wondered
of somewhere under
heaven there was a letter
or e-mail inviting her real name
to her class's 10 year reunion.
That notion made Roxy laugh as the
white van rumbled her life away.
"What's so funny?"
mumbled Star from the way back where
she road slumped amid suitcases,
sound system speakers, cables,
minispots, make-up and custom bag,
telescoping dancing poles,
and the deflated ring
for bikini wrestling gigs.
"What isn't funny?"
Cherry arched her back to stretch.
Potholes on this two-lane
highway across the top
of the state retailed the
minivan, but Roxy saw no tremble
in the breasts some surgeon built
beneath Cherry's red sweater.
Roxy thought, "Wonder if Cherry paid
back the loan plus [inaudible] Luke
fronted her for that work.
Wonder how much longer
I can keep him
from helping me go
under some knife."
Star said, "Nothing funny about
one of you skimming me stash."
"Not me!" said Desiree,
"And no way it's Bear.
Crystal would make his head fart."
Whoosh came Bear's back hand toward
Desiree, missed because a gopher ran
across the road, made him swerve
the minivan and messed up his aim.
"Almost," said Cherry of the
attempted varmint murder.
"Star, Luke's rules say
no rips, no hold-backs.
So there's no thieves in this ride."
Bear growled, "Don't
talk about Luke.
I'm road boss.
And no more asking to drive
or cozying up to the man."
"I'm just trying to stick
to my place," said Cherry.
Roxy said, "Nobody's
skimming you, Star.
You could tell.
Tweakers know tweakers."
So far Star steered clear of the
needle and the pipe, only sniffing.
She kept her high cheek bones,
tawny haired, stop-traffic beauty.
Her teeth and her tight TNA,
no tremor in her pony legs
when she stripped, but her
eyes were always black holes.
"Catch some sleep," Roxy told
the beauty in the way back.
"Sleep is when they
get you," said Star.
"You can really get got when
you're tweaked," said Desiree.
"Don't care then."
Desiree stared out the windshield.
There's a whole lot of
out there out there.
The Western third of the state
was the Rocky Mountains marching
down from Canada, pine
tree crags soring more
than a mile above sea level.
East of the mountains meant scrub
grass prairies and [inaudible] brown
and gold fields of rotated crops,
which, if you weren't born there,
looked like one terrifying
big empty.
In the two weeks Roxy had gone
to community college a teacher had
said Montana held seven regions each
bigger than many other states.
Where she was now was the Hi-Line
named for the railroad built
after the Civil War by a tycoon
who got free land along his tracks
from the Federal Government.
Got the feds to create cargo
and passengers for his trains
with public land giveaways
to homesteaders
who didn't understand it
rained next to never out there.
Before Roxy's lifetime,
when the glaciers melted,
40 below zero blizzards roared over
the prairies a few times a year.
Most homesteaders fled,
died, or went crazy.
The ones who stayed
leathered up rough and tough.
Like me, Roxy's eyes
found the van's mirror.
What the locals saw when she
stripped was chopped hair the color
of dirt, nothing special behind,
and up front two small for no more
than five dollar tips, ice eyes.
And no matter the hoots, hollers,
and creep games nobody ever saw more
than what she was tough
enough to sell.
Except Paul.
Dead rabbit on the road.
Bear swerved to run over it.
His mirror showed him mountains
shrinking 40 miles behind them.
They'd rolled east out to the
prairies, blew through Browning
on the Black Feet Reservation,
barreled through Cutbank
like that town wasn't there.
Coming up on the left horizon
Roxy saw three blue humps,
the Sweet Grass Hills,
mini mountains left
over from dinosaur days.
She stared out the window, said,
"Here come the space aliens."
Like an Army of giants
10 stories tall,
100 windmills with spinning white
blades rose from the prairie.
Big money invaders that, in
harmony with Montana's history,
were built elsewhere
and sent electricity
from the local wind out of state.
A dozen miles beyond the Army of
windmills waited Shelby and Paul.
"Yay! I got cell service!
OK!" Desiree said waving her
cell phone registered by Luke
through some gonna-bust-it account.
"Promise I'll work my gigs, but
first I need me some Candy Crush."
Every circuit girl had a
website for credit card chats
and private downloads with viruses
run by some hacker in Russia.
Once Luke's crew had gotten
all they were going to get
from a cyber troll, that citizen
might find his credit crashed
and his bank tapped.
A touch of that coming
back to Luke to be washed
in his payday dollars now
yellow shack on Bozeman strips
of warehouses, seedy
motels, and bars.
Luke kicked a slice
of the hack score back
to the women he put online
minus any vig they owed him.
Then there's the cash
from the dates.
Roxy didn't do that.
"Yet," Cherry had whispered to
her a week before in Lincoln.
The truckers in Unabomber town
the mountains there in Lincoln,
Roxy caught Cherry
sneaking back into the diner
from the highway patrol cruiser
parked out back, from the badge
who had a kink, Cherry
parleyed into law-man tips
that got her nods from Luke.
But that badge wasn't clocked to
meet up with Cherry on this circuit.
Cherry saw herself
caught in Roxy's eyes,
put a finger to her smeared
ruby lips, "We all got secrets."
Now, on that April morning,
the white van rushed past
the wind farm Army of towers.
Shadows from the spinning
blades slashed Roxy.
Cherry told the driver, "You're
belt's packing the take just fine."
"Shut up about my belt or
you'll get it," growled Bear.
Cherry ignored him, gave Roxy
a look about -- about the take?
There's the take and
there's the books.
The books are the circuit's fee
plus a cut of the door at bars,
bachelor blowouts, or frat house
gigs, negotiated taxes on beers
and booze, payout for
gas and motel rooms,
and independent contractor
fees to the stable.
The books are for the law.
The take is the everything else,
a cut of all the presidents tucked
into G-strings or tossed on a beer
stained floor, half the dollars
from dates cleared by the road boss
that Roxy still said, "no," to.
Desiree said yes to such got-to-pay
dates from the same kind of guys
who mocked her as, "Fatty,"
back in high school.
"So who's laughing now, huh?"
"Cherry picked," referring to
the big shots who were reeled
in by the blonde with big
breasts and big ideas.
Star let any guy with
the right cash hang her
up in whatever night he wanted.
But the major dollars in the
take came from the envelopes
that nameless mooks brought to
bear as they traveled the road,
cash laundered into the
books as gross income.
The books and the take, what they
say you do, and what you really get.
White signs on a green road sign
read, "Shelby, seven miles."
Bear's eyes goaded Roxy
from the rearview mirror.
"Maybe I'll stop."
Shelby'd been a gig on
the circuit last month.
A mesa rim float off to Roxy's left.
Up on the right she saw the
truck-sized flapping American flag
near the highway crossroads.
One road through town,
the other to Canada
or toward Great Falls past
the electrified chain fence
of a private prison.
The books claimed they'd
done great the first night
of their double header
gig in Shelby at Jammer's,
a former track side
slaughterhouse renovated to a bar
with a liquor license acquired from
a gone-broke tavern in polluted,
poisoned Libby 246 miles away
in the pine forested mountains
of the Northwest corner
of the state.
Jammer's owner clung to Shelby's
dreams that windfarm workers
and prison guards someday were
going to drop enough dollars in town
to banish the white wash
windows off Main Street.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> E.A. Aymar: You can
always tell a Montana story
because it has the
word, "varmint," in it.
Sujata Massey's Rei Shimura series
has been nominated for the Edgar,
Anthony, and Mary Higgins
Clark Awards
and won the Agatha and Macavity.
She's also the author of
"The Sleeping Dictionary"
and "India Gray: Historical
Fiction."
She has a new series
coming in January
from Soho Press featuring Bombay's
first female lawyer in the '20s.
The first book in the series is
titled "The Widows of Malabar Hill."
On a personal note, she's one
of the first thriller
writers I ever read seriously
and admire her a great deal so
I'm not going to poke fun of her.
Instead, I'll make fun
of Con really quick.
Of course nobody uses
fax machines anymore.
That's so out dated.
Why would anyone use a fax machine?
Here's Sujata.
[ Applause ]
>> Sujata Massey: Hey, I'm so
surprised everybody is still
around for the last reader.
But then I sat down
in one of those chairs
and I realized how incredibly
comfortable they are.
I mean, we should have these chairs
and bean bags everywhere
that we appear.
I'm going to read a little bit from
that first book in the new series
that Ed mentioned, "The
Widows of Malabar Hill."
And the lead character in this book,
who's going to be narrating
this section that you hear,
is named Perveen Mistry and
she's a young woman lawyer.
In fact, she's the first
woman lawyer in Bombay.
And she gets into a
lot of tight spots
as a woman lawyer doing
this difficult job.
And you'll see where she is.
I think you'll figure out
what happened to her just
as she's figuring it out too.
Cat out of the bag,
Bombay, February 1921.
When Perveen awoke, her throat felt
dry although her body was soaked.
She'd sweated maybe for hours.
She was wrapped up in
a thick, rough blanket.
Reaching out a few inches, she
tried to tug the cloth down,
but it just pulled tighter
around her curled up form.
And then she remembered.
Bruce Street and the shock
of a cloth sack coming
down over her head.
She had a memory of fighting
against it and then being hit.
She recalled a bumpy
ride and being hauled out
and hearing the lapping
sound of water.
She'd braced for the
feeling of sinking
like a stone into cold water.
She knew she'd end her
life in the Arabian Sea,
the body of water her
ancestors had crossed
to build their new lives in India.
At the Calcutta High Court,
Cyrus had sworn vengeance on her.
The years between that time had
been filled with the excitement
of Oxford, returning to Bombay, and
working as a full-fledged solicitor
in her father's practice.
Until the last few days,
she'd relinquished her fears.
The attack had caught her off
guard despite the warning signs,
and the plan would come
off without a hitch.
Her parents didn't know
about anything amiss
and enough time had passed
so there'd be no suspicion
of the Soda Wala family.
And her death, once
it was discovered,
would allow Cyrus to
marry a new wife.
A loud ship's horn interrupted
her thoughts reminding her
of another possibility.
She recalled the hulking
figure of Giant's boss, Ravi.
Ravi had been furious about the
changes Giant's legal victory had
brought about for all
the stevedores.
As revenge against her father,
Perveen, who'd shown her face
at the docks, could
have been abdicated.
Now she'd be left to die and
Ravi would escape prosecution.
But there was also
the Ferrite situation.
Someone involved might worry she
was getting close to the truth.
The telephone call from a
woman that had brought her
out at night could have been
a ploy and the disabling
of Ramchandra's rickshaw
had been intentional.
This, of course, pointed
to the attacker being
connected to the caller.
She'd been taken around
eight in the evening.
What time was it now?
She slid her stiff right
hand over her left forearm
until she felt the rectangular
face of her French wrist watch.
She could not read
the time in the dark,
but it was comforting
to still have it.
She wondered if she
had anything else.
Groping with both hands, she found
her beaded purse trapped in a corner
of the sack near her feet.
How surprising the
assailant hadn't taken it.
Perhaps it was meant
to be an identifier
after she was nothing
more than a pile of bones.
The fact she'd been left alive
might mean somebody was nearby
keeping guard.
She wanted to know.
Clearing her scratchy throat,
she began shouting in Marathi.
"What are you doing sticking
me in a bag like this?
Kidnapping's a crime!"
She shouted for five minutes
changing the language to Hindi
and then to English steadily
raising her level of profanity.
Hearing nothing but silence,
she gathered she was alone.
If she were truly alone,
she could try
to escape the bag without
interference.
Feeling more determined
than frightened now Perveen began
exploring the scratchy sack.
The top end was sewn
straight across,
but the end near her feet
was drawn tightly together
as if it had been tied with a rope.
She could not possibly untie
something knotted on the outside.
The only way out would be
to tear the straight edge.
Perveen searched through
her small, beaded purse,
which contained a few coins,
business cards, the vile of attar,
and her mother of pearl
fountain pain.
She removed a metal hairpin from
her braided coronet and tried
to stab it through the cloth.
The thin pin broke
on the 5th attempt,
but she really needed
a sharp bit of metal.
She thought of the whale
bones inside her brassiere,
but she didn't have enough space to
move her arms to unhook her blouse.
So she took the fountain
pen and rubbed its nib
against the sharp, broken hairpin.
It took only a few
minutes of industrious work
to give the pen's nib
a knife-like sharpness.
She was elated when
she pushed the pen
into the bag's fabric
and it went through.
Diligently, she stabbed the cloth
until she made an opening
of a few inches.
Then, with her hands, she tore
it open the rest of the way.
Squeezing herself out, she
slowly released her arms and legs
from the tight ball they'd been in.
Her right foot throbbed with
pain and so did some spots
in her back and one elbow.
But she was free.
In a short, dark space
that smelled of dust.
Groping around, she identified
many more sacks around her.
The crowding gave the
impression she was in a storeroom,
perhaps one of the many go-downs
built in rows near the harbor
or at Ballard Pier itself.
Goods were held for months and
sometimes years in the go-downs.
She remembered her brother Rustam's
frustration about a shipload
of nails that should have been
delivered to Mistry Construction,
but had been accidently stored after
the unloading and forever lost.
She tried to think logically.
She'd been loaded into this place.
There had to be a way
to the outside.
First, she searched the low ceiling
hoping to find the base of a shoot.
There was none, at
least not near her.
She shifted her investigation to the
cold cement walls around the sacks.
Moving made her feel the impact of
begin in a windowless, doorless box.
She was becoming frightened,
realized that not knowing
where she was in relation
to the bag she'd broken
out of made her feel lost.
Perveen said a silent prayer and
afterward her mind felt clear.
If she'd been brought to a
place already filled with goods,
she'd probably been left close
to the front of the space
and whatever door existed.
She crawled back to the spot
where the destroyed bag lay.
Then she sat down and
felt everything around it.
A raised edge on the wooden
base caught her attention.
When she touched it, she
realized it was one edge
of a large wooden square.
She was able to pry up the square
and pushed one of her hands through.
Her initial confusion was
followed by the realization
that she'd been loaded
up onto a shelf.
This was the reason for the
very low ceiling above her head.
The way out was to drop down
to the next level, though,
how steep the fall would be and
what she'd land on was unknown.
Sometimes people kept guard
dogs in the storerooms.
There were even rumors of
certain merchants keeping snakes,
which would dissuade
both thieves and rats.
She whistled to see if
a dog might move below,
but there was no sound in response.
Perveen slowly fit herself
through the opening feeling
her way down with her feet.
But then her tired arms
couldn't hold her anymore.
She slipped straight down
landing in a sitting position
on another group of sacks.
She sat there for a while making
sure no bones were broken, although,
when she gathered the
strength to stand,
she had a searing pain in her hip.
Resolutely, she bumped her way
around the room to the area
where she saw some
thin streaks of light.
A ventilated wooden
door, she decided,
after exploring it with her fingers.
Unfortunately, it was locked.
Pressing her eyes to the
narrow bits of light,
she realized the door was
near an area with people.
She heard the rumble of
men's voices and, again,
the blowing of a ship's horn.
She must be at the
harbor very close by.
She could hear voices.
That also meant someone
might hear her.
"Help me!"
she called in English
and then in Marathi.
She shouted again and
again, but nobody heard.
Perhaps it was still too early
or the storeroom too distant.
Starting around seven,
the dock became lively,
but then there might be too much
noise for a tiny cry to be heard.
She had to draw attention
to the door in hopes
that the earliest workers,
the tea makers, the sweepers,
and the stock loaders might hear.
Perveen put her hand in her purse.
She could write a note
and push it through one
of the ventilation holes,
but the laborers reporting
to work were all illiterate.
Then she felt the cool glass
of the vile of rose attar.
If she spilled it, she'd
create an overpowering aroma.
An expensive feminine
scent that was unusual
for the dock might draw men
to the storeroom's door.
If she could push the
ana and pisa corns
through the ventilation holes
they might catch someone's eye.
Perveen opened the vile and spilled
it along the open edges of the door.
Then, she pushed an ana
through hearing it clink
as it hit cobblestones outside.
"Take the money!"
she bellowed feeling like
a huckster at the circus.
"Money! Money!
Money!" Thanks.
[ Applause ]
>> E.A. Aymar: All right.
Thanks, Sujata.
And thanks again to
everyone for coming out.
I was purposefully not making eye
contact with our very helpful timer
because I know we're
a couple minutes over.
So thank you so much.
Thanks to the Library of Congress,
Colleen Shogan, again,
and Nick Brown.
If you enjoyed this event, but you
really want to hear more swearing,
our next Noir at the
Bar returns October 7th,
the Wonderland Ballroom.
Hope to see you there
and thanks again.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.